these are all Jewish fighters Emily
Kagan Rory singer Neola hi Maurice Inga
I know Rory he does any self [ __ ]
jewelry and filly Steven Steven singer
playing on singer Rory singer looks like
a Viking the Ultimate Fighter back in
the day boss what do you think of Rory's
body well let me see if yeah let me see
him fly I'm it's not bad it's ready I
mean I want more rip than that yeah
right yeah took his shirt off
let me tell you something on steroids
what happened used to have a problem
yeah really yeah the crack why I was I
was a drug addict I mean I started
getting high when I was you know 15 16
on with okay has been [ __ ] by other
smoking freebie yeah so that's probably
right you know now you never had to do
you never liked how they give an eye
oral for drugs did you I did it for fun
no I mean coach about it but you know I
mean I've done terrible if you give an
all kidding aside I'll [ __ ] punch
through your hats
shut up you know it's changing [ __ ]
little Stretch Armstrong q16 they don't
[ __ ] love growth hormone and steroid
at 60 everybody was 60 and renting so
wait no when did your marriage fall
apart